[Music]
foreign
okay so today I'm going to tell you
about how we can solve partial
differential equations using the LaPlace
Transformer I've been looking forward to
this lecture for a while so I gave a
lecture on Laplace transforms and how
they relate to ordinary differential
equations you know well over a year ago
and I have had a series on Vector
calculus and partial differential
equations for a while now and now I'm
excited that these two can meet in the
middle so we're going to solve pdes
using Laplace transforms I think this is
going to be two videos and the first one
I'm going to show you how to solve the
heat equation using Laplace transforms
and in the second video I'm going to
show you how to solve the wave equation
using Laplace transforms and this is a
really really powerful technique to
solve pdes so remember Laplace
transforms for Odes they turn ordinary
differential equations into algebraic
equations they're going to turn partial
differential equations into ordinary
differential equations so Laplace
transforms almost always make your
problem simpler to solve and in the case
of pdes it's going to make it simpler to
solve by turning them in to ordinary
differential equations
for a long time now known how to solve
partial differential equations using the
Fourier transform so I have a bunch of
lectures on how to do this numerically
using the fft to numerically solve pdes
either on periodic domains or on
infinite domains uh but also
analytically we know how to solve
analytically pe's using uh the the
Fourier transform and Fourier transforms
are good for pdes on an infinite domain
kind of where X goes on forever negative
Infinity to positive Infinity where we
have decaying boundary conditions so if
I had you know a thin metal rod that
went on forever and I have some
temperature distribution in the middle I
can solve for the kind of heat equation
as that evolves in time using the
Fourier transform if I have infinite
decaying boundary conditions
but remember the Laplace transform is
basically like a Fourier transform for
nasty one-sided functions and so just
like I can solve pdes on an infinite
domain with good boundary conditions
with the Fourier transform I can solve
pdes on a semi-infinite domain on kind
of a one-sided domain with other
boundary conditions using the Laplace
transform good so Laplace transforms are
good for pdes on a semi-infinite domain
maybe I'll just I'll write a couple of
little notes to myself so these are good
Laplace transforms are good for pdes on
a semi-infinite domain semi-infinite
domain
where I have boundary conditions and an
initial condition so where I have
boundary conditions and initial
conditions with b c's
um let's let's say with with a boundary
condition and
initial conditions
and so here I'm going to illustrate this
on the heat equation u t equals u x x we
derived this you know a few lectures ago
conservation of thermal energy in a
metal rod but here instead of our metal
rod going on from negative Infinity to
plus infinity here it's just going to
start at x equals zero it is going to be
semi-infinite so we're going to assume
that that wire goes on forever that way
or at least it's so long that it doesn't
you know for my purposes it's
approximately infinite and we have an
initial condition
um
some initial temperature distribution
maybe I'll write it down our initial
condition is going to be U is the
temperature at every location X at every
time T and so our initial condition is U
at every point x at time 0 and I'm
actually going to solve this you know
for a specific initial condition and for
a specific boundary condition you can
figure out how to solve this for a
generic initial conditions and boundary
conditions later I'm going to assume
that my initial condition is a sine of
4X so I kind of Drew this wavy sine wave
that's my initial condition
uh let's write it here this is my
initial
condition
and I'm just going to tell you one of
the punch lines is that when you Laplace
transform this partial differential
equation this initial condition is going
to act just like the forcing term did
when we LaPlace transformed our forced
ordinary differential equations so
remember from like control theory or
systems theory when you have your
ordinary differential equation plus
forcing and you Laplace transform it the
way that that forcing enters is exactly
how these initial conditions enter this
problem they're going to enter as
forcing so this is kind of like a
forcing term and you'll see that in a
little bit
would it be color coded here if I can my
notes got printed in in grayscale so
it's going to be a little bit of a fun
exercise for me to see if I can remember
what colors go where so we have it in an
initial condition and we also also
boundary condition and I'm just going to
assume that my boundary condition is on
the left and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to impose a temperature on this
left boundary condition maybe I have
like a little heater and some controller
some PID controller to make that you
know a constant or a temperature that I
prescribe at this left boundary
condition and so that's going to be you
at position x equals zero for all of
time T I'm just going to specify that
the boundary condition I'm choosing with
my little controller is that the
temperature at this point is e to the
minus t
at
x equals zero
maybe I'll just be very explicit this
was at time T equals zero and so that
boundary condition if I if I look at
this you know if I plot kind of uh
uh of t
versus T we just have some exponential
decaying temperature at this left
boundary condition and again you know
maybe I have some little radioactive
element that's like exponentially
decaying maybe I have a little heater
and a PID controller and I'm just
specifying this temperature profile it
doesn't really matter but this is the
problem we're going to set up so it's a
heat equation on a semi-infinite domain
with an initial condition and a boundary
condition and we're going to solve it
using Laplace transforms
now I can't uh neglect this opportunity
to remind you that although these
techniques are very powerful
they are also a little bit anachronistic
and Antiquated so we still definitely
want to understand how partial
differential equations work kind of
intuitively and one of the best ways we
can intuitively understand how these
work is through things like the Fourier
transform or the Laplace transform
go to solve problems on with pencil and
paper
and so you'll see in textbooks and in
lectures almost all of the examples that
you actually have solutions for are on
these kind of idealized domains right we
solve the heat equation laplace's
equation earlier on a rectangular domain
because that's the only domain not the
only but it's one of the only domains
you can easily solve it for on one
Blackboard in 30 minutes there are you
know Transformations so I can solve it
on a circular disk or on a semi-infinite
domain but solving for the heat
Distribution on an F22
that's a hard problem and it's very hard
to do it analytically with pencil and
paper so we need to use computers for
those Solutions but it's still important
to understand these canonical
configurations and these classical
Solutions so that we gain intuition when
we use computational Solutions or even
you know more recently machine learning
Solutions so just a reminder you know we
do these things on idealized domains
because that's what we can do on pencil
and paper or on a light board
and because that's what the tools you
know admit solutions for but those
Solutions still give us lots of
intuition when we apply these to more
complicated systems good
okay so the goal now is uh we're going
to solve
for
U of X comma t on the domain on x
is you know greater than or equal to
zero and less than infinity and time is
you know greater than or equal to zero
so that's and also less than infinity
now here's where it gets kind of
interesting so we're going to Laplace
transform this pde and we're going to
use these initial conditions and
boundary conditions to try to solve this
system
um but I I have a choice of what
variable to Laplace transform with
respect to I could Laplace transform in
time I can Laplace transform in space
and until you get some intuition for
this it's not that obvious which one's
right
so I actually often ask my students
um you know at this point in the lecture
like which one should be Laplace
transform should be Laplace transform
time or space
um
and it really depends what you're going
to start building intuition for is it
really depends on your initial
conditions or your boundary conditions
kind of what initial information you
have will determine if you want a
Laplace transform in space or in time
uh so in this one I'm just going to kind
of tell you the answer we're going to
Laplace transform in time specifically
because of the nature of our
um we have the initial condition to do a
Laplace transform in time because we
have we have one derivative in time
and so when I Laplace transform I'm
going to need one kind of initial
condition in time and I have one initial
condition in time if I LaPlace
transformed in space I would need two
boundary conditions somehow because I
have these two derivatives and I've only
got one boundary condition so that's
kind of one hand wavy answer for why I
want a Laplace transform in time and not
space and we'll revisit this at the end
of the lecture so
good so we're going to Laplace transform
uh with respect to time
so a kind of Laplace
this is my notation for Laplace
transform with respect to so this is a
lot of math notation Laplace transform
with respect
to time the time variable with respect
to time
with respect to time t
we're going to Laplace transform with
respect to time T and we're going to use
our initial condition when we do that
this is because
because we have
a single
derivative
in time
and one
initial condition Okay so for example
I'm going to do this for the wave
equation u t t equals uxx now I've got
two derivatives in time and two in space
so if I have two initial conditions all
Laplace transform in time but if I had
two boundary conditions I would Laplace
transform in space so you really have to
to think about which uh you what you
have enough initial data to Laplace
transform with respect to
okay so so this is the easy part we're
just going to do the LaPlace Transformer
we're going to Laplace transform with
respect to time and so remember that if
I uh Laplace transform with respect to a
variable I get something like
um
s s is my Laplace transform variable my
LaPlace variable my frequency domain
variable this is kind of the analog of
the Fourier frequency for LaPlace s
times U Bar U Bar is my Laplace
transform of U
[Music]
function of space and time it's a
function of space and my LaPlace
variable at
so this is a function of X and S because
I'm LaPlace transforming with respect to
time
minus
U of X comma zero so this is going to
again have the same this is going to act
like a forcing term
forcing term
this equals
the Laplace transform of uxx and again
these are derivatives with respect to X
not with respect to time so it's
basically U Bar x x it's the second
partial of U Bar my Laplace transform
State U with respect to X so this is
just U Bar x x you'll have to convince
yourself that when you have a function U
that's a function of space and time if I
only Laplace transform with respect to
time
then I get U Bar of X comma s and if I
for example take the second spatial
derivative of that it's just U Bar x x
that's totally fine so all I've done by
LaPlace transforming is I've removed
this time derivative and turned it into
s times U Bar
but in doing so now this is an ordinary
differential equation in X I have U Bar
and its derivatives in X but I have no
other partial derivatives so this is an
ordinary differential equation in X that
I can solve
good so this is I'm just going to write
that out this is an ode
squeaky ode in X and it's second
order
and if I really wanted to I would say
you know I'd move stuff over on the same
side and I'd say this is maybe I'll just
do that this is going to make my life
easier so this is you know u x x bar
minus S U Bar
equals minus
U of X comma zero okay and remember this
is going to be my forcing term this is
not Laplace transform Laplace transform
this is actually
this initial function of X this is a
function of X these are LaPlace
transformed quantities U bars
and so
you solve this ordinary differential
equation with forcing
is first you act like the forcing is
zero and you find the homogeneous
solution with with forcing zero and then
you add on the particular solution that
satisfies this particular forcing uh on
the right hand side so essentially we
have the homogeneous and the particular
solution I'm just going to write these
down because it's pretty easy so
essentially what we have is
I'm just going to stick with with yellow
here so essentially what we have is uh U
Bar of X comma s this is my Laplace
transform temperature
is equal
to if this was a zero forcing here
essentially this would be a second order
ordinary differential equation u double
Prime minus s times U and so the
eigenvalues are
plus or minus square root of s
plus or minus square root of s so I have
subconstant a
e to the
minus root S times x
plus another constant B times e to the
plus root s x
plus whatever my particular solution is
of X comma s okay and if I was being
really clever I would have color coded
this pink because this is my due to my
forcing term this is my particular
solution
uh particular solution
you want to you know dust off your voice
into Prima or your ordinary differential
equations I'm sure I have some lectures
on this or I'll be making some where you
know if you solve an ode with forcing
you saw you act like the forcing is zero
to get the homogeneous part of the
solution and then you find you add on to
that this particular solution that
satisfies that forcing term okay this is
kind of how we've always done it
um
and I'm going to make a point these
constants out front those constants need
to be determined just like again you
know based on your initial conditions or
your boundary conditions just like you
would normally do in ordinary
differential equations you would you
would determine these coefficients by
like you know the first and second
derivatives uh you know U at zero and ux
at zero but now be because this is a
LaPlace transformed function these are
actually going to be
uh uh LaPlace domain functions these
coefficients are like LaPlace functions
I'm not going to explain that again I
we're going to assume that these
coefficients are functions of the
LaPlace variable s and then we're going
to see that those need to be functions
of the LaPlace variable to satisfy the
initial conditions and boundary
conditions Okay so
we LaPlace transformed in time we
haven't used our initial condition yet
but we can see that we're going to to
find our particular solution
um and we have determined that this is
the basic form of the homogeneous
solution
now we know
that for this to be a bounded solution
as X goes to positive Infinity this term
has to be zero this B has to be zero
because each of the plus you know
exponential in X grows without bound as
X goes to Infinity so this term has to
be equal to zero
um this B has to equal zero for what we
call a bounded
solution
which is kind of another boundary
condition if you think about it is that
we want our solution to be bounded as X
goes to Infinity so this is the only
term we have for the homogeneous
solution plus this particular solution
okay good
so I am going to
um
determine this particular solution using
my initial condition
and then I'm going to determine what a
bar of s is using my boundary condition
using this boundary condition so that's
the last we're going to essentially
solve for this using we'll use
our boundary condition
so here we're going to use our initial
condition
and here we're going to use our boundary
condition and so that's that's kind of
the next two steps in this procedure so
we have taken this problem LaPlace
transformed in time the basic solution
has to have this form we kill this term
so that we have a bounded solution and
then the particular solution we're going
to choose to satisfy this initial data
forcing here and this a bar of s we're
going to determine using our boundary
condition
okay this is gonna be a little messy uh
there's no way around it so I think what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
Barrel through
and we're essentially going to determine
this
um
particular solution using our initial
condition and I'm going to try to stick
with pink as much as I can here
so we're going to to find
to find a PSI bar of X comma s we are
basically going to assume
we know that it is going to have the
form of whatever X of X comma U of X
comma 0 is which is sine of 4X and so
the way that you you usually find a
particular solution is that you know you
assume that your solution is going to
have the same form of Sines and cosines
of 4X
so we're going to assume
we're going to assume
that PSI bar of X comma s is equal to
sum of cosine
of 4X
plus a sign
of 4X and again these are going to have
undetermined coefficients there's going
to be some LaPlace C of s and some
LaPlace D of s and we're basically going
to find the C of s and D of s that if I
plug this in to this differential
equation it satisfies that
um you know U of X comma 0 equals sine
of 4X okay because this is my initial
condition that we're plugging in here
that's how undetermined coefficients
works you just kind of guess a form of
the solution that you know if you took a
bunch of derivatives you might get
something that's kind of like that
forcing term and then you determine the
coefficients so that when you plug it
into that differential equation you
exactly get that forcing term and you
get this thing equal
okay
of a mass so what am I going to do I'm
literally going to take PSI
and I am going to plug it in
two
this
equation is that right
um
yep that's what I'm going to do so I'm
going to take s times PSI minus sine of
4X equals the second derivative of PSI
with respect to X
it's a mess
times PSI
is
s
C of s
cosine
and I'm not going to keep writing cosine
4X sine of 4X I'm just going to write
cosine
Plus
s times D of s
INE
okay that is
s PSI
s PSI
minus
U of X comma 0 minus
sine 4X
equals
PSI XX I'm literally plugging PSI in
every time I see a U Bar I'm plugging in
this
PSI and I'm taking its second derivative
here with respect to X and I'm going to
do it in my head I hope uh so the second
derivative of cosine 4X with respect to
X the first derivative is minus 4 sine
4X the second derivative is minus 16 cos
4X
so I'm definitely going to have a 16
times minus c bar s
coast and the second derivative of sine
again is minus 16 sine so minus maybe
I'll pop this negative sign out front
so I get a minus 16 c s cosine plus d s
ine and I'm just going to check my notes
because it would be a disaster if I
botched this at this stage I'd never
find what went wrong
so this is correct s c cos plus s d sine
minus sine minus 16 C cos minus 16 D
sine good okay and this is
um
this is PSI bar x x and this is my
initial condition forcing
you just like you could do this if
someone woke you up at two in the
morning you could do this algebra it's
not it's a little irritating but it's
not difficult okay so we are trying to
determine this particular solution so we
plug it into the partial differential
equation uh assuming that it has a form
kind of like the thing you know that our
forcing terms some Sines and cosines of
4X
and now I'm going to collect all of my
like terms and try to get a function an
expression for C of s and D of s
and so I think what this is going to be
is something like
um
how's this going to work we basically
are going to collect all of our cosines
on one side uh in one term and all of
our signs in one term so all of our
cosines
we have S
c bar s
if I move this over I get plus 16
c bar s
cosine
4X
Plus
now I have S D of s s
D of s
minus 1
well let's say minus you know plus 16
D of s because I'm bringing this term
over that this has a sign on it minus
one
all of that times sine 4X
and we know that all of that had to
equal zero so all I'm doing is I'm just
moving all of my cosine terms over and
grouping them and all of my sign terms
over and grouping them and that will
have to equal zero so this is all my
cosine terms this is all my sine terms
and now for this to be true for every
for all of X this has to equal zero and
this has to equal zero and so that means
that c of s clearly has to be zero so C
of s
has to be zero
and D of s
is basically s plus 16
D Bar of s equals one
implies that D Bar of s equals 1 over s
Plus 16.
so we essentially have determined now
that our particular solution PSI is
equal to
zero cosines
plus 1 over s plus 16 sine 4X and this
is where it gets a little funny you'll
have to convince yourself you have to go
through the various steps each point and
convince yourself yes in fact this
undetermined coefficient out here is not
a constant it's not a number it is a
well it is it is a constant with respect
to space because this is LaPlace in time
but it is not just a number it's a whole
Laplace transform function a transfer
function D Bar of s
so I'm just going to write this down so
that I don't forget it so PSI of X comma
s equals
1 over s plus 16
quantity times
sine 4X this is
my particular solution
to this ode so this is one piece of the
solution and now I need to find the
homogeneous solution so we used our
initial condition to find the particular
solution I just wrote it down here we're
going to save that for later and now we
need the
um
boundary conditions to solve for this
homogeneous solution
okay good
um
I hope you're all with me so far I'm
just maybe I'll do a quick little recap
and then we're going to keep going this
is a long lecture I'm going to make sure
okay I got battery for now so I better
hurry
um
we are solving this pde in space and
time using the Laplace transform
remember when we solved the heat
equation in steady state we didn't think
about how things evolved in time we just
solved in the limit of T goes to
Infinity so to solve how things actually
evolve in space and time is a little
more tricky you either need the Fourier
transform on an infinite domain or the
Laplace transform if you have a
semi-infinite domain
since we have semi-infinite we're
LaPlace transforming with time and when
we will Applause transform with time the
initial condition acts like forcing and
the boundary condition is going to be
how we solve for this a bar of s in the
homogeneous part of the solution
homogeneous solution particular solution
so now we're going to determine this a
bar of s using our boundary condition
and once we've done that we will now
have this you know this will be
determined and this will be determined
and all we'll have to do is inverse
Laplace transform with respect to time
and that'll be our solution so that's
all we have to do now and I hope this
doesn't isn't too difficult and maybe
I'll do this one in blue
I want to give myself some space here to
work so that I don't cut my head off
um
so I think now we determine
determine a bar of s
uh by setting
essentially by setting x equal to zero
and using our boundary condition
okay and using our boundary condition
okay good so we're are going to set x
equal to 0 here
sine of x equal to 0 is 0 e to the minus
root S 0 is just one so essentially
if I set x equal to 0 U Bar of 0 comma s
is just equal to a bar of s
that's really simple
um
that's really really simple
and we know that U Bar
of zero comma s is equal to the Laplace
transform
of our boundary condition U at zero
comma T U at zero comma t
which is the Laplace transform of e to
the minus t and the Laplace transform of
e to the minus t is just one over S Plus
t
one over sorry 1 over S Plus One this
equals 1 over S Plus One sorry I
shouldn't have said S Plus T So a bar of
s equals 1 over s plus one because
that's the Laplace transform of my
boundary condition
so now I have my homogeneous solution
and my particular solution and I can
combine them okay so this is uh the last
step I'm done after this so don't uh
Don't Panic we're basically done
so now what we have is the solution in
the frequency domain so the solution
in the frequency domain
and I'm just going to write this out is
you bar X comma s equals the the
homogeneous solution which is 1 over s
plus one and now you see why this
undetermined coefficient
is a function of the LaPlace variable s
it's not just a constant it's a it's a
transfer function which is a constant
with respect to space again because this
is Laplace transform in time so you know
this whole thing is a constant as far as
space is concerned
but this is a transfer function it's 1
over S Plus One
e to the minus root S X plus the
particular solution Plus
1 over s plus 16
I hope that's not s yeah that's s over
16.
sine of 4X
so to some extent we're done this is the
solution of my PVE this is the app this
is the Laplace transform of my solution
so for example if I took this initial
condition in this boundary condition and
I you know simulated It Forward in time
I could essentially Laplace transform
that solution and get this uh this this
is the Laplace transform of the solution
at instead of this being a function of
time this is a function of the LaPlace
variable
so now the last thing is if I want to
get back a solution in the time domain I
have to inverse the floss transform this
so in the time domain
in the time domain
we essentially say U of X comma T this
is too faint I'm just going to go back
to Yellow U of X comma t
equals
the inverse Laplace transform of this
whole thing and remember if I inverse
Laplace transform
the inverse Laplace transform of the
product of your two functions is the
convolution of the inverse Laplace
transform of each of those functions
so this is Laplace transform inverse of
1 over S Plus One
convolution integral with the inverse
Laplace transform of e to the minus root
s x
plus the inverse Laplace transform of
this thing
which is 1 over s plus 16
times sine of 4X because this is a
constant with respect to the time
variable
this is just uh you know the the
Laplace transform of a convolution is
the product of the Laplace transforms so
the inverse is also true and now all I
have to know is these three inverse
Laplace transforms and two of them are
really really easy these are
exponentials and I claim that the
inverse Laplace transform of something
gaussian like this is another gaussian
I'm just going to write down the
solution
so this equals
U of X comma T equals
uh this inverse Laplace transform is e
to the minus t
convolution integral with this inverse
Laplace transform and this would be a
whole 20-minute lecture to derive this
inversal plus transform I'm just going
to write it down this is kind of a
textbook formula it's not that
interesting how to derive this one but
it is the inverse Laplace transform of
something that looks like a gaussian is
another gaussian
so it's uh e to the
minus 1 over 4 T 1 over 2 root pi
uh T cubed something weird like that
Plus
and this is again e to the minus 16t
sine
4
X
and I am pretty sure
somewhere there should be an X
in here
um okay so here is the part in a lecture
where you might get a little frustrated
because there is absolutely a typo
somewhere in here
because I know that this had a this was
a function of X and so somewhere here
there should be an X maybe this should
be like an X cubed or there should be an
X in here somewhere okay and so you're
going to have to
um
essentially go to your textbook or go to
Wolfram Alpha or Mathematica or whatever
and find the inverse Laplace transform
of this function here where inverse
LaPlace transforming with respect to s
and whatever you get just substitute it
in here and fix my typo so it's actually
kind of a nice little homework exercise
because you'll see exactly what changes
when you get the right expression for
this inverse Laplace transform I should
have brought my textbook
but it doesn't really change any of the
philosophy of how you solve this problem
you basically you know Laplace transform
in time to get this expression which is
an ode in space with some forcing my
initial condition becomes a forcing term
I solve that ode in space and I get this
expression that has a homogeneous and a
particular solution
one half of the homogeneous solution is
zero so that my solution doesn't blow up
as X goes to Infinity
the other
part of the homogeneous solution I solve
with my boundary condition
and my particular solution I solve with
my initial condition and I just do that
using kind of standard ode techniques to
solve for you know a bar of s using my
boundary condition a bar is just the
Laplace transform of my boundary
condition my particular solution is just
some transfer function times my forcing
function sign my initial condition sine
of 4X
and when I go through all of that math
what I end up getting is my my honest to
goodness solution of my my function U of
x and t in the Laplace transform domain
so all I need to do is inverse Laplace
transform this and I get my solution in
the time domain
okay and at least two of these inverse
Laplace transforms are really really
easy because the Laplace transform of
um
you know the Laplace transform of e to
the minus a t is just one over S Plus a
so this Laplace transform and this
Laplace transform are really easy this
one's a little bit gnarlier but I'm just
going to say you know go to wolf from
alpha go to your textbook type this in
and get the inverse Laplace transform
that's the function that'll go here it's
going to look like a gaussian in time
it's going to look like a time gaussian
and so as time increases the variance of
the scausion is going to get wider and
wider and wider which is essentially
going to smooth out
uh is essentially going to smooth out my
um
my solution as time goes on so that
that's we've known this intuition for a
while that um and I actually derived
this in my Fourier transform solution to
the heat equation as time goes on
essentially the solution diffuses and
diffuses and diffuses and so you
basically have this kind of
um gaussian kernel where the variance
increases or spreads as a function of
time but again there's definitely a typo
in here I can see it clear as day
because there should be an X somewhere
you can fix that by just typing this
into wool from alpha and plugging in
that solution here and then this will be
the honest to goodness full solution in
space and time of the temperature
Distribution on the semi-infinent domain
okay that was a lot but I hope you found
this to be kind of uh a little bit you
know empowering that you can actually do
this yourself for these types so so try
different initial conditions try
different boundary conditions you know
make this cosine of 4X or you know e to
the minus X and change your boundary
condition make this sign of T you know
change things around and see how things
change in this formulation all right
thank you